so this is a very very very nice sample
of very fine copper wire so the copper
wire here is what width is this this is
point I'm looking that's just too too
small copper is unusual among the metals
in that it's coloured it's really only
copper and gold that are colored so you
can see here we have copper coins in
fact you can see this one looks brighter
than that one that's a modern one that's
been plated and you can see it's a
slight cheat because modern UK coins
although they have copper insides have
iron inside so with a magnet you can
just pick them up but the proper copper
coins are not magnetic at all so it's
point one of a millimeter so the copper
wire here is very very high grade this
is grade one copper wire and it's point
one of a millimeter in diameter and you
can see the wonderful copper is luster
copper and compounds are not very
reactive in fact if you put iron filings
into copper sulfate or some other copper
salt the copper coats out on the iron
filings which are gray and then they go
a nice sort of rosy color almost like
gold it's often one of the first
experiments that people do as chemists
so this is very very high purity this is
like 99.99% copper used for electronics
fabrications and high quality research
samples it's a very beautiful sample on
the other hand and quite surprisingly
that copper chloride is quite reactive I
did an experiment once in which I took a
cupcake container which made Van Leer
mininum and put copper chloride in it
solution and it boiled I was trying to
demonstrate how reactive it was to my
children I didn't notice that the copper
chlorides had burnt through the
aluminium and made a hole in our sitting
room carpet most organisms you and me
use iron in a black
to transport oxygen that's what makes
our blood rate but in some sorts of
crustacean crabs and Simmel lobsters
they're different they use popper they
use a compound called hemocyanin it's a
blue compound of copper cyan is some
classical word for blue so they really
had blue blood and these hemocyanin uses
two atoms of copper and each molecule to
transport the oxygen around the body of
the crab or lobster it's not nearly as
good as hemoglobin so if you start
running after crab or lobster it quickly
gets tired compared to running after a
rabbit or something like that which can
keep going faster than you can